[Música]
o camp é a segunda doença que mais
pessoas mata aula
ao longo de todo o planeta é
caracterizado por um crescimento celular
descontrolado de células que vão
esquecer o que deveriam fazer e onde
deveriam estar
e isto este encontrou é causado por que
a informação genética que já se falou
que está contida nas nossas células é de
alguma forma alterada multada
dizemos nós o câmbio tem três grandes
fatores a sua base em sua gênese para
que surjam estas mutações essas
alterações
a primeira é nossa e teria dado pelo
influenza são conseguimos dos pais e das
mães segundo o modo como vivemos já que
o ouvinte as nossas escolhas de areia ea
terceira também já ouviu falar dela é
sorte ou falta dela pensando pela parte
mais detalhe e dady parte do natural
quem na verdade é uma conseqüência
natural do nosso desenvolvimento nosso
crescimento todos nós começamos como uma
célula ou fecundava onde metade da
informação de métrica vinda do pai
militar também se juntaram para fazer de
nós todos os concertos completamente
diferente completamente individuais e
essa é a primeira célula vai ter que
tornar em 23 em 48 e por aí fora e as
chamas o fim de muitas muitas divisões
vão formar um segredo quem neve tem 30
40 bilhões de células que são 30 40
milhões de milhões de células e nós não
paramos de ter célula em divisão desde o
primeiro dia da primeira célula até o
diego remus exportemos se diz como por
exemplo sam precisa de ser proposto
periodicamente em tom de festa
naturalidade o desenvolvimento do cancro
vem porque é a primeira célula do todas
trazem informação genética não é que o
chamado à dengue e as informações
genéticas vai ter que ser duplicada para
que façam duas células e depois 4 e 28 e
todas as células do nosso corpo
na verdade com têm exatamente a mesma
informação genética embora uma israel
são células da glia tem que estar no
cérebro é fazer neurotransmissão outras
celas que havia que estava em tempo
terem bons que tem que bater e depois
existe céu e também sabe que tem que ser
do dedo mindinho do pé esquerdo mas elas
todas clube é mesmo informação só de
maneira diferente
portanto neste processo de revisão que o
coloco ao longo da nossa vida e não se
assusta mas o número de revisões ao
longo da nossa vida está acima em ter
levantado 16 10 o número de divisões que
nós passamos
e desde a primeira o que acontece é que
nós temos uma das proteínas amigas as
quais eu gosto de chamar os monges
copistas que tem que copiar a informação
está na primeira célula e daí pra frente
sempre tem que copiar aquela informação
genética que ladeia ano e nós pensamos
no a dengue como uma frase longa onde
está toda a nossa informação essa frase
tem 6 mil milhões de letras
não é de admirar que de vez em quando
monges copistas vai enganar e vai
introduzir um erro em vez do fmi ontem a
vez de um apoio um ano e portanto é
prazo a palavra dessa letra estava vai
perder sentido ea sessão pode começar a
ficar um caso baralhada a mãe natureza
sabendo que tinha criado um sistema de
cópia que não estava livre e eu fiz um
backup magnífico que é os mosquitos
pistas tem umas amigas que vai entrar
também elas proteínas que vão lendo que
os fazem está tudo bem
isso não está de volta atrás é pagam e
fazem e como diz um amigo meu se o
primeiro não pode ter algumas falhas a
queda só fica bonita se a segunda não
for prefeito tinha e importante estas
segundas o eficácia desta segunda as
proteínas e esta é de extrema
importância para que não sejam
introduzidos erros nós a dengue que
depois possam ser propagadas por em
diante mas infelizmente também essas não
são livres de euros
então o que acontece é que nos vão toda
a nossa vida em todas estas
oportunidades rever erro e se eles vão
circulando inevitavelmente nós
células e que acontece é que quando
esquerdo um certo número uma certa
combinação essas células vão prover os
função do ciclo de função e vão poder
começar a cheirar descontroladamente
não é por isso de espantar que os
clientes sejam mais comuns nas pessoas
de idade mais avançada que já tiveram
mais oportunidades de errar tiveram mais
divisões iriam vocês estão umas e não a
pessoas jovens e também dentro a essas
duas dessas pessoas normalmente têm um
dos fatores que contribuiu com muita má
sorte e acho que já as poucas que já
acumulou foram e sítios cruciais para a
informação da célula onde parceiro ou
então já herdaram dos pais alguma
informação estava errada e provavelmente
muitos de vós ou talvez todos sabiam do
caso das linhas da lei que fez uma
mastectomia profilática porque sabe que
tem uma mutação no seu dna um gene que
está associado não vale sem risco de
desenvolver cancro da mama e e do ovário
não é uma decisão simples e fácil
pessoalmente uma pessoa tão didática e
vivo também da sua da sua imagem
o que acontece é que existem certas
famílias onde a execução passado os pais
para filhos e normalmente o que estes
erros
a cury ficam é para as proteínas amigas
que vêm atrás dos golpistas é que elas
são mesmo essenciais que funcione bem e
porque é que as pessoas então tem perto
mais prováveis de desenvolverem mais
cedo é porque como as conquistas como
essas proteínas amigas que têm entradas
corretoras vêm mais velhas não conseguem
ver onde estão todos os erros e portanto
vão deixar passar mais erros
as duas vão formar mais ricos e mais
pressa ao longo da vida
por isso a sua sorte o seu prato da
sorte e do azar vai estar inclinado para
o lado do rosário e esse é o lado
natural do carioca e faz parte do nosso
desenvolvimento desenvolver erros e
portanto esses erros poderão
eventualmente chegar em formação uma
célula eo para o desenvolvimento
mas sei que nesta sala deve cerca de mil
pessoas o que os números em portugal
dizem é que nós 4 1 em cada 4 nós vai
ter tem 250 do nosso mercado é que a
área específica da mini ficção tem sido
nesta prevenção dos erros herdados do
pai do ponto do pai da mãe e por exemplo
o trabalho em casa me cerca de 800
mulheres em portugal são diagnosticados
todos os anos mas somente somente 10%
dessas oito mil mulheres é que tem campo
provavelmente devido a causas reservadas
ainda assim o meu trabalho e tentar
descobrir todas essas causas herdadas
todos esses xix a informação pode ser
incorreta para cancro da mama seus quer
o fim da minha carreira tendo salvado
uma mulher que seja você uma cientista
concretizará
mas como diz são só dez por cento a
percentagem de kant familiares é muito
pequena comparada aquilo que nós
chamamos os clientes por alex são
primariamente devido a causas ambientais
e as nossas escolhas de estilo de vida
já se falou aqui também sobre isso
250 e nós aqui que vão ter o carinho que
tem pelo menos uma boa notícia para ao
longe que é 100 desses casos poderão ser
completamente evitados porque nós
fizemos as escolhas certas
o gerente ambiental a nossa escolha de
vida é que está associado a um maior
número de cancros é o fundo trabalho
sabemos perfeitamente qual é que a
alteração química que faz não é com a
dengue e conseguimos que ele é mesmo
identificá lo na informação genética
temos hoje em dia a tecnologia permite
escolher aquelas seis mil milhões de
letras numa célula em um dia uma coisa
impensável há cerca de dez anos atrás
que nós hoje iria conseguir sequenciar
dizemos nós um tumor olhar também
influenciar as células normais num mesmo
paciente fazia de 3 e ver onde estão as
alterações daquela informação genética e
com isso ficamos a saber
saber por exemplo se o trabalho foi um
player nesse desenvolvimento porque
sabemos qual é que o fim de 30 é a marca
química que deixa que deixando a dengue
e não é só o cancro do pulmão o que no
fundo o trabalho está associado ao
aparecimento de tumores
outro que em quase todos os sistemas
outra associação claríssima que nós
vemos entre a observar o aparecimento
cargo obesidade aí um canoísta já não é
tão preciso nós pensamos que é um pouco
mais indireto tenha vínculos células
gordas que fazem é produzir hormônios
hormônios que vão afetar a velocidade eo
modo como as nossas células dívida e lá
está a ser feita a revisão afeta é que
eu lanço do dono mutações que nós vamos
acumulando ao longo da vida e sabemos
claramente pessoas obesas têm um risco
muito mais elevado de vir a desenvolver
com pessoas que não são obesas que tem
um índice de massa corporal mas mais
normal mas dentro das normas
o terceiro fator está em portugal e tem
que falar eu embora quem portugal falou
meu em termos de praia estivesse agora
até toca no reino unido e faria
provavelmente os usuários e radiação
ultravioleta cabeça ultravioleta
conseguem encontrar a nossa pele e ir
até as células que estão responsáveis
pelo posição da nossa pela longa vida o
que acontece também o uso vez conseguem
mudar as informações genéticas nessas
células e ao longo da vida vamos
acumulando acumulando até que um dia nós
temos um nome a um outro cancro da pele
se as pessoas tivessem cuidado com o
modo como se expõe ao luxo ultravioleta
a radiação ultra-violeta metade dos
cantos de papel podiam ser evitados e
portanto já mostrei aqui que existe uma
parte evitar vender uma parte não
evitava jazz também falou nisso mesmo
que se tenha uma vida completamente
solar é uma dieta equilibrada e
atividade física mesmo que nós tenhamos
a nossa informação genética é impecável
senha caminhão ainda assim existe
são ao acaso e portanto existe uma certa
dose de sorte na vida precisamos ter
para não desenvolver
quero mas não conseguimos pro prevenir
todos os casos então uma coisa que nós
tentamos fazer também a nossa
investigação é tentar ser um dos quais é
que são as palavras que mais
frequentemente aparecem alteradas pois é
que são as informações mais conhecimento
alteradas para conseguirmos também
perceberá que drogas são os mais
adequados para cada paciente porque não
conseguimos produzir então tratemos cada
vez melhor e este chamados nós ensina
personalidade precisão como jogos dessas
mutações ocorrem um ano de vida em
sítios múltiplos e um cada um relatório
tanto nenhum cancro
o cancro das da vizinha do primeiro que
não é igual quem cozinha do sul um
direito não devem as duas ser tratadas
exatamente o mesmo dia 13 a pew de onde
chegamos hoje em dia que vamos começar é
conseguir sequenciar cada do mouro e
começar a dar o corpo é certa cada
paciente para o seu tratamento em sua
sobrevivência sejam mais eficazes e para
que consigamos evitar os efeitos
secundários adversos dos tratamentos que
são um dos grandes maus do que é
exatamente o efeito do tratamento
espero que a espanha conseguiu
transmitir nossa escolha um grande fator
para prevenir o quinto é nossa escolha
de hábitos de vida os fatores ambientais
espero que da próxima vez que estejam no
computador ou escrever qualquer coisa e
erram fazer um erro e tem que ser o
eleito e depois que vê novamente
lembrando as nossas células
errar é natural
[Aplausos]